A few years ago, I just wore black,
my inner state also became black.
But when I discovered the neon, I was really happy.
I like this color.
And I began to dress again in color.
It really became a craze,
I started doing my neon creations.
How are you doing here? The current has caught me several times.
That gives me the liveliness.
The lights of neon really fascinate me
because they are more than a stationary art work.
They have this gas leaping inside the pipes.
When placing the neon in a very dark environment
Suddenly he becomes beautiful.
It helps me to see the world under a new light
and approaches more people.
Josefin is also the Creative Director for Forza Football,
where it creates football apps that bring fans closer to the game.
Josefin Eklund.
Artist of neon lights.
Creative apps.
Evaluation of application creators around the world.
Share your #IMakeApps history